And today we're going to be talking about dirty electricity, and I have a great guest today,
Bede Ericsson from Satic Company, a product that we sell in our store, and it's just fantastic.
We've tested it with leaders. Very excited about it. We use it at our house. We use it at our office.
So Bede, thank you for being on the Zoom call today and sharing your time with us today.
You're certainly welcome. It's my pleasure. I think there's some confusion. I know everybody has
heard a lot about EMFs and the dangers of EMFs, but I'd like to do a few of these calls if I can
have you back another time, I hope, but today I want to just concentrate on this concept of dirty
electricity. I think that's kind of new to people. Can you explain what that is?
I'm happy to do my best. It is kind of a bit of a moving target, and in some cases, it depends
on whom you ask. What's dirty electricity? To maybe a surge suppression company like Belkin,
I mean, we all own a myriad of Belkin little power strips or surge protectors in our home
to protect from surges. So maybe if you asked one of them, Dr. Comers, they would say, you know,
hire voltage. Voltage that's outside of set parameter. Maybe they would say that's dirty electricity.
Hard to, you know, argue that. To a stereo company that wants, you know, that crisp audio sound for
your audio file, maybe they would say that ticker pop in the speakers, which is distortion. Maybe that
's dirty electricity. Hard to argue that. I think for us, what we're really talking about is dirty
electricity that might be harmful to a bio-organism, harmful to my plants, harmful to my pets, harmful to my
child or myself. We have a slide here that I just pulled off the internet. Is this kind of good
rendition of what you're talking about? That is. So what we see here on the left, we see a clean
sine wave. And so you've got two waves. You have your voltage wave, your average wave. And in this
picture, we only see one, that's okay because we're going to assume that they're in phase. They're
so close together that it looks like one. That's actually what you want. On the right, we see these little
peaks and valleys that almost look like a, for a little caterpillar. And those are transients.
Those are abnormalities, distortion, and harmonics on the electrical wave. Now, because of the FDA,
I certainly want to be careful about what I say as harmful to a person that I'll tell you what,
Dr. Conner's, a myriad of information has been written about.
Dairy cows. Dairy cows do not like this form of dirty electricity. Really, this 900 hurts this
distortion on electrical lines. It is well documented to affect their production of milk, which could
be mood, you know, at some level, and quality of milk. I was on a hood or right, Dairy not too long
ago making a joke about the electric fence. Everybody likes to kind of horse play for some
reason around the electrical fence, or at least men do for tend to push your buddy into it.
And we've made a joke that a dairy cow, you know, how he would respond. And this dairy owner said,
no, no, no, dairy cows never get stung by it. Never. Why not? They don't go near it. They don't like it.
They can absolutely feel it within a couple of meters and move away. They're very sensitive.
And much has been written about the negative effects of this dirty electricity on dairy cows.
Also, greenhouses, a tremendous amount has been written about big succulent strawberries,
big succulent tomatoes, that you get a better product if you're not exposing these bioorganisms to
dirty electricity. So for me, it would track, I'm not a cow or strawberry specifically, genetic, I'm
bio, I'm extremely complex, I'm extremely sensitive. If it's measurably bad, measurably harmful to these
other things as a person, as a clear thinker, it just tracks for me as a person making my own
health decisions. And it wouldn't be good for me that it would affect me in that same way.
Well, our practice is mainly cancer and some chronic line patients. They're all knowledgeable about
EMF said the possibility of that being at least a partaker in their cancer. And certainly most
by chronic line patients are very sensitive to EMF's and dirty electricity. We're all exposed to it.
Is that correct? You know, absolutely. We live in an electronic world. We all have electrical
lines coursing through our homes and our offices. You know, one of the things I remember as a youth,
I mean, in my 40s, in town, I mean, in an automobile, you listen to either a cassette, or maybe a CD
if you're lucky, in the radio. In town, you got really great EMF-AM reception. Once you got on a road
trip and you got out of town, you had to switch to EM. And that was a result of a two-foot,
three-foot antenna made of aluminum, probably, or some pot metal on the hood of our car. Well,
your home is a super antenna. It's a super antenna. It's not two feet of aluminum. It's a mile of
copper, high quality copper. So what's happening is as the dirty electricity that A comes from the utility
and, or B, that you make, and don't blame the utility, most of us accidentally make a lot more
dirty electricity in our home than the utility delivers. Through what? Through our devices.
Devices. Devices. Computers, as you've got. Lighting. Wi-Fi. And the number three, so number one,
delivered by the utility. Number two, creating your home. Number three, landing on this super
antenna that is your electrical system. Right. So there's the three main ways it gets there,
but then do you want to live there? Do you want it to live at waste high or knee high?
When you lie in bed, most of us put our pillows on the side of the bed that's touching the wall.
Well, it's almost the exact height within a foot or two of where the electricity is moving through
that wall. So imagine now that you lay your head down right by these electrical lines that are
coursing with dirty electricity at 60 hertz. If it is bad for you, if that's true, you don't want to put
your face by it for seven hours. Okay, you're scared of me. I'm scared of myself.
Well, it is true. And you wonder why our incidents of cancer has gone through the roof.
I mean, this is at least a piece of it in my puzzle here. Now everybody's wondering, okay,
well, this is all great knowledge, but it is scary. What can I do about it? And let's move to the
next slide to talk about that because you have some solutions. We do. I'm going to brag for a moment.
I know it's not becoming, but I'm going to do it because I'm really proud of our team. We have some of
the best engineers definitely the best engineers that we could find in Western Montana.
Our lead engineer as a PhD in engineering from MIT. I don't know that it gets any better than that
in the US. The guys at Caltech might say so. We have a second engineer, Brian Havlovick,
that has made incredible rushless motors that even to this day power the Tesla automobile,
a larger version of that. And Brian Jackson, who's done over a billion dollars in megawatt wind turbines.
All three of those gentlemen are on staff here. And we've spent the better part of a decade
designing a really unique line of power conditioners. Power conditioners, the engineering word for an
electric filter. The electric filter is going to want to remove an abnormality, a transient, a spike,
something that is outside the parameter of the specific amount of electricity and phase and
current and in frequency that your device wants. And so that would exclude harmonics distortion and
the things that you and I call dirty electricity. So what did I say there? We've got some of the
finest filtering products for electricity that are available on the market today in any country,
any price. And I mean that sincerely and from the heart. And what we use here at the office is the
one on the left here, the plug-in unit simply because we're in a large space and I'm not going to
have access to the power panel. This the one on the right is the one that the best one it has.
Does it have 16 capacitors in it or something like that? Yeah, you know, so I don't I'll be careful
saying best. It has more guts, but really the base set of the technology is the same. And there's
a lot of ways to get there. So some products name brand that a lot of your customers have used a 20
or 30 microfarad capacitor. It's a fixed state. It's a fixed value. And then you would plug those
in or sprinkle those around the house. Some use a magnetic choke. It's almost like brake water
for a bay or a brake water for a lake property. Some use harmonic rectifiers, which is a very small
kind of nano filter. Others use resistors. I mean anytime you plug in a curling iron or you turn
on your stove or plug in your clothes iron you lower the dirty electricity in your home. You do it
in an effective way. But it's not an efficient way. Well, what's that mean? It's like a jet
electricity, right? Yeah, they use a ton of electricity. So it's, you know, it's an expensive way
to get there. And so our product is a combination of those technologies. Very small, staged capacitor
banks, harmonic rectifiers and veresters. We do all three in one with the outcome being a superior
result that doesn't increase your bill, but actually lowers your bill. And we're the only product
that we are aware of. There might be somebody out there. I don't want to be disingenuous. We're the
only product that we know that effectively filters the electricity and protects your home from surges.
And in most cases, lowers your power bill oftentimes significantly. We've had multiple patients tell
us that they noticed that their power bill went down when they plugged in the units. Lovely.
So it's very nice. So we sell these, we sell the ones on the left there as a set. That's how we
sell them in our clinic. Because to my knowledge, you need one of your each side of your
handle box, the wires that are coming down. Is that correct? You do. So when you buy the product
inside the instruction manual, explains how you get each of the phases. So in residential power,
it's called single phase. Well, that's not correct. There's two phases. So why something with two phases
was named single phase? I'm not sure. But you have two phases. You have 120 volts coming from A,
which should be half of your outlets. You have 120 volts coming on B, which should be the other half
of your outlets. And sometimes you see a breaker that has two levers, two poles, P-O-L-E, not P-U-L-L,
you're getting 120 from A plus 120 from B. And that's your 240. That's the only difference between 120
and 240. Are you grabbing one of the wires? Are you grabbing two of the wires? And that's the difference.
It's lost, yeah. It's lost. So we've got to get one of the units. We call that unit the EMF
eliminator. We've got to get one on an A and one on a B. And then you have full home protection.
And it's not... I always tell people, if you plug them in two different outlets,
there's a 50% chance you do it perfectly. If you put them in two different rooms,
you're at like an 80% chance, you get it right accidentally. So it's not hard. It's not a mystery.
We don't want anybody to be afraid that they wouldn't do it properly. We'll make sure they do it right.
Well, we're very happy with ours. And we measured our... You know, we have a plug-in meter that we
could measure the dirty electricity from each outlet. And in the clinic here, we went from a reading of
like 650 or something down to 40 when we plugged these in. So that was really fun to see. I can't
remember what my home one was at. But I was more concerned about the clinic here because it was just,
you know, every office has Wi-Fi and, you know, it's an older building. And so it's... You just have
more issues. So dealing with EMFs is a struggle, I think, for a lot of people because you can't see them.
We had really a fun time today because I purchased a new little EMF meter and we were
measuring EMFs coming out of all our phones that are computer devices and stuff. And we have a
little phone, EMF blocker. And so we could measure how well it was working. And it was pretty
cool to see it work well. So it's need to be able to show patients that you could measure the decrease
in the dirty electricity and EMF function by using devices like this because nobody wants to get
scared. So, you know, we appreciate your input. We appreciate your work. And I just told more people
couldn't get this. These are for sale. If you're watching this video and you're a patient of ours,
just go to our store. If you're not a patient of ours, go to our website and you could buy these too,
just by clicking on where the big red arrow is on the top of our website. It says store. And then
search for EMF because I have it listed as EMF home protector and the plug insets or the wired sets.
And you can purchase it right off our website. BD, thank you so much for coming on. I do hope that you'll
take me up on another invite to talk about some other things and other products that you have
any last words. You know, the only last words are, you know, I want to thank you for the time.
And I want to encourage everybody. Please buy these from Dr. Conner's store. Sometimes people think
maybe it might be easier to call factory direct. We're not a store. We love you. We want to help you.
But we're not a store. We don't have a cash register or a factory. We ship these in large containers.
Dr. Conner's buys them in bulk and keeps a nice inventory. And therefore his price that he's
offering to you is going to be better actually than any price we could give you because we would ask
that you would buy a carton or a container. So please don't get creative and try and call the factory
direct. We're just not set up for it. Dr. Conner's has gone to a lot of work and a lot of research
to set this website and get you great pricing. Please use that resource. Also, he's going to have him in
stock where you'd save on shipping potentially and some other things if you live in this area
or he could get him right out to you. So I just want to make sure that people follow the proper
channels and trying to get our distributed goods. And that's it. Well, thank you very much.
This is our free shipping if anybody wants to know. There you go. Thank you again. And we will
talk again, hopefully very soon. We look forward to it. Thanks, Doc. Okay, bye-bye.